- I'm Paul North.
I'm a professor in the
German Department at Yale,
and I'm not a TV
personality or a producer.
So we're just technologically.
And in terms of this medium flying
by the seat of our pants,
our collective pants.
So you'll forgive us if it isn't perfect.
These are "The Franke
Lectures in the Humanities"
This series is called "The
Value of Marx's Capital."
You'll get a little bit
of a play on words there.
The series is a companion
to an undergraduate seminar at Yale,
which is on Marx's "Capital, Volume I."
And it also is in conjunction
with a new English translation
of "Capital, Volume I"
done by my colleague
and collaborator on this Paul Reitter
from OSU who's here.
I'm co-editing it.
But Paul is doing a really sparkling
crisp and rigorous translation,
which will be out with
Princeton University Press
in a couple of years.
So we're taking the opportunity
to work through the book with students
and bring in luminaries
to go through it with us.
I have to give a couple of thanks.
First, The Franke
Lectures are made possible
by the generosity of
Richard and Barbara Franke
and are intended to
present important topics
in the humanities to a
wide in general audience.
I'd like to thank Alice Kaplan
the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center
who was behind this
project from the beginning
and is taking the center
in amazing directions.
Sandra Malan-Bowles who
coordinates it from the Whitney.
Leana Hirschfeld-Kroen who did all
of the organizing work, I thank her.
And Audrey Leak,
who is our technical whiz kid.
Let me say a couple of things
about how the workshop will run
for all of you here and also
for those students in the seminar.
Professor Musto will give a presentation
with some breaks in it where
we'll have some conversations.
After that there'll be a Q&A
starting with the students in the seminar
just to give them a chance
to get their questions in.
And then we'll open up
the floor to questions
from anybody who has them.
Let me ask you the not
to post your questions
until I give the signal
they will simply get lost in the chat.
So we'll ask you to put
them in the chat in the Q&A
I will give a signal first
to the students in the seminar
they can ask their questions
and then I'll open it up
and we'll try to get to all
of your questions in the chat.
If you need to leave,
or you can't make another
of these sessions that
you're interested in,
they're being recorded
they will show up on the Whitney
Humanities Center website.
about two weeks after
the workshop we hope.
Also, I want to say just
doing all this business
that if you want to register
for subsequent workshops you can
only register the week before.
So keep your eyes out for that.
One important act today
I think maybe the most important
is to reassess our
vocabulary of revolution.
Marcello Musto has become the emcee
of this reassessment, the ringmaster.
I think I've been enormous
and enormously careful
returned to Marx's texts
as sources for new
understandings of vocabulary
we think we understand.
He's gonna talk about
one of those words today.
I want to start each of these
with a quote from the author.
Here's a quote from an
article on communism,
by Marcello Musto quote,
"The alternative to capitalist alienation
"was achievable only if
the sub altern classes
"became aware of their
condition as new slaves
"and embarked on a struggle
"to radically transform the world
"in which they were exploited,
"their mobilization and
active participation
"in this process could not stop however,
"on the day after the conquest of power,
"it would have to continue
"in order to avert any drift towards
"the kind of state socialism
"that Marx's always opposed
"with the utmost tenacity and conviction."
A moment of Musto's pros.
Now I'd like to turn the microphone
over to my collaborator, Paul Reitter,
who's a professor of German
at Ohio State who will intro
introduce Professor Musto.
- Thanks, Paul, and
welcome Professor Musto.
It's such a pleasure to
welcome you to our series.
Marcela Musto is a professor
of sociology at York
University in Toronto.
One of his most recent publications
is entitled "The Marx Revival"
and interestingly subtitled a new concepts
and interpretations or key concepts,
excuse me, and interpretations
and this speaks to what
Paul was just saying
about his interest in
engaging very rigorously
with particular categories today
rereading them, reassessing them.
And we see that in his work
on "Alienation" as well.
If you've read the article
that was disseminated on "Alienation"
you know that he writes
with tremendous erudition
and clarity, enviable really and
to come back to this title
that I just mentioned "The Marx Revival,"
there is a Marx revival
and Professor Musto is doing truly more
than any other scholar I
can think of to advance it.
He's in addition to the qualities
that I just mentioned
he's incredibly prolific.
He's given over 50
interviews in recent years,
written over 50 newspaper articles.
And also his list of publications
as much too long to go through
in its entirety but to mention
just a few things he's
edited on anthologies
on "Capital" 150 years later
he has a massive anthology in the works on
or handbook really on
the global dissemination of capital
and the history of translations
of capital around the globe.
He's also offered many books as well,
most recently the single
with many single authored books as well.
Most recently, "The Last
Years of Karl Marx,"
which just appeared in
the spring I believe,
and is really a marvel of compactness.
It's a biography of Marx's last years.
Archivally very rich,
conceptually very interesting
not very long either.
Really it's a great deal for the reader.
And I'd like to mention also
that it was printed in Italian
and came out in 2016.
Just to round the time
that the big wave of Marx's biographies
was starting to really
take shape and come at us.
And it was translated very effectively.
Let's not forget the translator here
by Patrick Kamler into English.
It's really wonderful to
have Professor Musto here.
The title of this presentation today is
"Marx's Conception of Alienation."
Thanks for being here.
Thanks everybody.
Good afternoon and good evening to
for the people who are listening now.
I am indeed very grateful
for your invitation for
your generous words.
Very, very generous words.
And I am very happy to be here
with Professor North
and Professor Reitter.
I will call you Paul and Paul
if I may even this is the first time
that we talk to each other.
I'm sure that we are going
to talk about this later
but I was extremely happy
when I heard this fantastic news
that "Capital" was going to have
a new translation in English
at this time, very important.
And we had such a prestigious
publishing house like Princeton
we'll discuss this later
but it was wonderful to have this news
and to put together this to
interest for Marx like the importance
of reading Marx very carefully.
My work has been as
theological as possible
but at the same time,
trying to use what Marx rightful
understanding our societies, our issues.
It is also a very strange talk for me.
And I will try to make some jokes.
It is the first time
in my life that I talk,
not being standing like
just sitting at the table
because generally I to stand.
And I also used to speak
as a young activist at
university in Naples.
I'm Italian I was in Italy until then.
I had to leave and go to
Berlin to study English.
And then I moved here in Toronto in 2009.
I would like to start from
a couple of biographical notes
if my host allow me to do this is.
Because perhaps it's useful
is interesting for the many
students or researchers
will listen now.
So we are in this
period of rediscovery for Marx,
and I will introduce a couple
of topics that I hope I will be able
to discuss with Paul
North and Paul Reitter
and then later with more people.
But when I started to speak about Marx,
I have another email now, can you hear me?
- We hear you find Musto.
- Somebody who turn the microphone on
I saw another face.
When I started to read Marx.
So when I entered my PhD in 2002 in Italy,
I was actually the first researcher.
The first personal was going to
defend the dissertation
after so many years
in such a big and important country
for Marx's study like Italy.
A dissertation in entirely on Marx.
And later when I moved to Berlin,
when I started to go there
and I spent some time at the
Berlin-Brandenburg
Academy, Friedrichswerder,
which is the institute for social science
where the new addition,
the new critical additional,
Marximum Engels writing
it started in 1998.
That's restarted.
I remember that my perception
of Marx changed dramatically.
And one of the points
that I would like to make
today about "Capital",
later we will discuss about this
is that after the MEGA,
after this enterprise,
that I was present in a minute.
Looking at "Capital'
like a book of three volumes,
this classic set
that I had seen many times in my life
and comparing these three volumes
with 15 volumes and this
huge critical apparatus.
So every volume in the
MEGA is 500, 700, 800
pages of apparatus
so this is the second section of the MEGA
which is called "Capital"
in his preparatory manuscript,
is a big change.
It's a big change for
us, for readers of Marx.
I will go back to this point very soon
for the moment I would
like to discuss with you.
I would like to discuss
with Professor North, Professor Reitter,
Paul and Paul.
I would like to put a couple
of cards on the table.
And the first question is what kind of
revival Paul just said
that there is a revival
of interest for Marx.
We know this revival mostly
because of what happened after 2008.
After 2008, one more big
economic and financial crisis.
And Marx is back in
Europe in North America,
after 20 years of silence practically.
So the Marx that we are reading
is most of the Marx that could be
the critique of political economy,
the critique of capitalism
and Marx was celebrated on
many important newspaper,
liberal conservative.
It doesn't matter.
Like the person who is still useful
for us not to understand capitalism
including publishing
some wonderful articles
that Marx wrote in 1857, 1858
at the time of another
big financial crisis
that started in New York 150 years
before the crisis they're opted in 2008.
I remember I was in Berlin
buying the front foot that I'll get miner
and being so shocked of
seeing two full pages of
reprinting of the famous
article on the economic crisis
that Marx wrote for the New York,
New York Tribune in 1857.
But in other parts of the world
actually there was another reading
of Marx or another interest of Marx.
For example, in Latin America
Marx was rediscovered a few
years before the 2008 crisis.
And the return to Marx was
I would say more political
than the one that we had
in Europe and in North America,
we got the contradictions we the problem,
but it was a Marx that was alive
and was perceived as something useful.
Now, something that people will need.
And if you ask me after
this many years of work
of collective work
like trying to connect young researchers
and institution universities
and try to rediscover Marx,
Paul North read this
citation at the beginning.
So it's clearly a Marx
that is very different
from the traditional Marxism-Leninism
in the 20th century, et cetera.
But if you ask me where I've seen
the most interesting
things in which country
I will say that Brazil is definitely
the place that caught my attention
more than anywhere else.
I remember some people will be surprised
because today Brazil is not
the place where there is the most
progressive government
or at the moment there are not
very strong social movements
like in the past couple of years,
but the attention in the universities
and in this research group
that are not closed merrily to university,
but they're open to look
at the contradiction
in our societies,
the attention for Marx
or for an author that I also very much
like Antonio Gramsci,
but let's just stay too Marx
so there is really impressive.
I don't wanna say, give
wrong numbers, et cetera.
But I think that there
are at least 150 centers
of research around Marx
and Marx his studies in
Brazilian universities.
And when I went there to
meet some of these scholars,
I was impressed by the
fact that many of them
were extremely young.
So they belong to a generation.
It was actually younger than mine,
and they had new demands
that new enthusiasm and
that new new topics.
And I wanna return to this
question, a new topic,
because I believe that
the Marx that is read now
in the last two, three years and
Paul Reitter was very generous
when he described my book
"The Last Years of Karl Marx."
But my force in the publication
of the book was trying to rediscover
a Marx that is very different
from the perception that
we have of this author,
a perception of an
author who has dedicated
his entire life merrily studying
or fighting politically the contradiction
between capital and labor.
There is much, much more in Marx.
And I am very happy to
see that the majority
I will say of the books
of the studies published
in the last two, three
years are opening topics
that neither were
never or very rarely associated with Marx.
For example, ecology,
for example, gender emancipation
for example, migration,
nationalism, colonialism.
I believe that there is a lot of Marx
that must be discovered.
And I believe that the
last part of his life,
the last 10, 15 years
from the international 1864, 1872
to the year that Marx died in 1883,
there is a lot that will be done there.
And this is the task of a new generation
of scholars or researchers of translators
in particular of translator Paul Reitter,
because there is very few
of Marx that has been
published in the period.
And I hope that we can discuss this.
I'm not lost in my talk,
but I'm trying to follow what I promise.
So this first
group I prepared five
and the first one will be a sort of
the Marx survival today in the world.
So I would like to say that
I discovered also other kinds of revivals,
for example, in China.
It is impressive the amount
of books that were translated
in China in the past 15, 20 years,
not only there is a new very scholarly
vigorous and serious additional Marx
and Engels writings that
these translating also
for the first time from German
and not from Russian,
some writings of Marx that
before at legal circulation
or translation are very
ideological reading
but in China that has
been also a big opening
to the so called Western Marxism.
Or if you don't like this
terminology too many European
and North American authors.
So there is a new generation
of Chinese students in particular,
in humanities a little
bit in social science.
And I will say my experience,
not at all in the economics.
So I know the paradox
that is repeating now also in China,
that is very interested in Marx and also
in this new reading.
So I've always seen China
as a place to compete,
as a possibility to enter
and also listening to
what these scholars are doing are saying.
So I am the acquainted or over serious,
that is called Marx-Engels,
Marx's new dimension.
And my most important at effort
in terms of editor is translating
from Spanish, from Brazil,
Portuguese, sorry, from Chinese,
from Japanese countries
with a very strong and lively tradition
in terms of Marxist studies translate
this thing into English
because sometimes this
readings of Marx are different.
And I find that interesting
to discuss this different options
these different ideas of Marx.
I stop here on this point
but if I ever please,
two more minutes,
three more minutes
I will like to come back to the question
of what kind of Marx is
read today at university?
I spend a lot of time looking at
all the syllabus around the world,
and unfortunately I'm not going to
share good news with you.
This is at least my understanding
of the situation in my opinion.
I've seen that the Marx at today's read
in many department of politics,
political sides in the world is the Marx
of on the Jewish question
which is a very brilliant
actually writing.
Unfortunately this writing,
which is not called the Jewish question,
but on the Jewish question,
is reply to an article written
by Bruno Bauer called "Jewish question"
that was never translated into English.
Well many times people do not understand
what is the real polemic about.
And then there is all the
party in favor of Marx.
The party against Marx.
Marx is doing bad things.
Marx is saying all with the perfect
and the right things but this text,
it is surely a text
that is not representative
allow me to do this provocation
but I'm sure that my discuss some
will understand it is not
representative of Marx's politics.
If you want to read Marx
you have to read Marx at the
time of the international
and why the text is not there
because Marx at the time of international
is a very complicated
a complex mix of writings,
documents, declarations, speeches
that he did with the
exception of the civil war
in France is not easy to combine
and have a clear idea of Marx's positions.
If you look at sociology
in the department of sociology,
a big majority of them
they read the German ideology
but today the German ideology
you invited Terrell Carver last week
perhaps he mentioned this,
I'm not bothering you.
I'm not taking time with this
but today we know that the German ideology
we know more than before is not a book
is not the ideological Bible
the four historical materialism
that Soviet Union adorasky created
the head of the institute
for our Marx-Engels-Lenin in 1932.
So if we read that the
pages on the division
of labor in the German ideology,
we know that this is just the beginning
of a very long journey
and they cannot be
compared with "Capital."
But once again,
"Capital" is a complicated, deep book
and if you want to extract parts
from there it is a difficult task.
- [Paul] Can I ask you
a couple of questions?
It looks like he is spotlighted
and I'm not showing up.
I'm not sure this is a problem.
Cause we wanna make sure that
the people who ask questions..
Or do you all see me when I'm speaking?
- I do.
- Yeah.
I just don't see myself.
I want it to, well, first I wanted
to thank you for the picture of a kind
of textual international,
which we hope proceeds the fifth
or whatever international is coming
a political international.
It really is encouraging
for people who read these things
to know how much is going on.
Also for the picture of a
reconfiguration of the Corpus,
which is an interesting phenomenon.
And I think we all need to say
where to start reading Marx
where to go next.
What for what pitfalls to ignore.
I wanted to ask you though,
in this world flowering of Marx studies
and in the reconfiguration of the Corpus,
what role does alienation play in that?
You're gonna talk about alienation today.
Is it a hot button issue?
Is everyone worried about alienation?
Where should it fit in the new program?
- Thanks. And when I talk too much,
like when I pass the 12 minutes
and more or less we are
located for each block,
I will be very grateful
if you or Paul Reitter
you just stopped me
very politely as you did,
but you helped me to move forward.
Surprisingly I want to discuss,
I want to answer briefly shortly
and then I will expand this.
Surprisingly, even though alienation
is a topic on which there were
so many books written in the sixties
in the seventies and
alienation was I would say,
as relevant as the topic globalization
has been for us in the past two decades.
Really everybody wrote about alienation
and I can think in the sixties
and in the seventies,
in many disciplines in sociology,
in politics, in psychology, literature
few terms at the fortune of alienation
and Marx alienation not
conception of alienation,
which is the title of my talk.
My contribution today
was the most important
element of analysis.
Despite this, when you
publish on alienation today
and when you put actually
the word alienation in the title,
I notice that there is
an incredible interest,
even more than usual.
And there are many books
many articles published on
alienation or on fetishism.
So in this rediscovery of
Marx in this "Marx's Revival"
I see that there is a lot about alienation
and about fetishism.
And let's try to discuss together.
Please help me.
I need your help.
Why this is possible?
I have an answer.
I will try to provide my idea, my opinion
and then we'll see what you two believe.
And then there will be question criticism.
So even though alienation
for us is a classic
in the Marxist thoughts.
And if we look at the topics alienation
is perhaps one of the top five topics
like Marx's alienation is as important
and Marx and communism
and Marx and critical political economy.
I want to say that this phenomenon
is something very, very recent.
And here I'm talking to the
students who are listening.
I will be a little bit boring
for those who are big Marx experts.
But I would like to spend a couple
of minutes discussing this with students.
I lost Paul North for the moment,
but he's back now.
So why alienation is something new?
Alienation something because the text,
which is not a book
but it's a very, very
first stage manuscript
that Marx wrote for himself,
the famous "Economical and
Philosophic Manuscript of 1844,"
which is to complete what I was saying
before the most important
text in terms of philosophy.
So what is read about
Marx in the department
of philosophy and not only
they're all over the world,
one of the most sold book
in philosophy in the 20th century,
this text was written by Marx in 1844,
but was actually published in 1932.
And the fortune of the
"Concept of Alienation"
is actually very much
related to this text of Marx.
Because when this book
was publishing in 1932,
now everybody would say,
it was the beginning of alienation word.
No, not at all.
One year after Hitler took Germany
and they were trying
to burn Marx manuscript
and the manuscript of Marx were sent to
London and then Denmark
and then they ended the majority
of them in Amsterdam,
in the beautiful Institute for
International Institute
for Social History.
But before the end of World War II
so and of the forties,
second part of the forties,
beginning of the fifties this texts,
the "Economic and Philosophic
Manuscripts of 1844"
was not known.
It was unknown.
So the concept of alienation starts
to have this important place
in the tradition of Marxism,
only after the publication of this text.
And also the question of fetishism
to go back to "Capital"
because there is this famous section
that I will try to discuss later
when we approach the fourth point
of our conversation today.
But if you look at the debate
in the second international
in the third international,
if you look at the
books article written by
Koski, Lenin, Ben Stein, Labriola, Sorel,
they didn't write about
alienation about fetishism,
even do fetishism was published
and was there since 1867 or
actually Paul Reitter since 1872
because it only when Marx
did that new German edition
that fetishism appears in a better way.
So I'm also asking your
questions to my discussant.
So alienation is a relevant place today
because it is considered one
of the main topics for Marx.
This tradition started
in the early fifties,
like 70 years ago.
And I will say most importantly than this
because we never lived in such an
alienated society like today,
that's the most important answer for me
like a researcher that is not only closed
in this room office in the university.
So I believe that Marx is relevant today.
Of course many of his
analysis must be updated,
must be changed.
There were many mistakes
many Lehman's problems
like every other thinkers
but capitalism today is so spread
so much globally in
every region of the world
and is so present in
every aspect of our life
that I cannot think about another concept
that is as relevant as this one
that can be used as this one.
The question and I stop here
and I pass the microphone to you.
The question is to understand what
Marx's really meant for alienation.
Because there are many different ideas
many different approaches.
And I don't know if you
want to go there now
or if you want to wait a little bit more.
So let's see what my
discussant and also think.
- Well, I think you do a very nice job
of framing the some of these questions.
I mean, you did a nice job here,
but also in the article
that that was circulated and there is a
long running debate
about the relationship between
Marx's early views on alienation.
Alienation as it's
framed in the manuscripts
that you were just talking about.
And the way of talking about
what is in effect alienation
that Marx has in "Capital."
And I was excited.
I read your article really just
before we started this event.
And so I'm actively still processing it,
but I was excited to see how you frame
the fetishism section of
"Capital" in the context
of this discussion of alienation
and this very artful genealogy
of different ways that alienation
has been picked up on
reworked in the various
traditions of Marxists theorizing.
I mean, I think that with fetishism,
the appeal of that section,
I mean, it has multiple levels of appeal.
One is that it's been influential
in a certain kind of cultural theory
that remains influential
and people who come to Marx
from that side of things
or would those affinities
will feel drawn to it.
But I think that as
capitalism expands becomes
more complex I think
there's a more pressing need
or a more urgent desire to work
through its mystifications.
And this is as for me at least
the most rhetorically powerful attempt
in capital to formulate the
mystifications of capital
how capital as a system throws off
false appearances and misleads people,
and the role that these
mystifications play
in its ability to dominate them.
That was more a comment than a,
like a question exactly.
- No, I actually, I like this very much
because this is completing what
I was trying to say before.
And I also prepared something that
unless you and Paul
North disagree with me,
so now I'm gonna share the
PowerPoint a little bit
a little PowerPoint that I prepared
so that the students who are following
are not scared about this big concept
and definition that we provide,
but perhaps they can read.
So I have selected a couple of definition
from the article that you just mentioned,
and then we might want to go back
on this topic later,
but what you told me
it's very useful for me
because it helps me to move forward
in this discussion about
what kind of alienation are we reading.
So that conception of fetishism,
it was so powerful and
it was already there
from the very beginning
but arrive as you said.
But arrives to the attention of
activists not only scholars but activists.
Only after there is this big interest
that is at the beginning
of philosophical interest,
I will say for, for alienation.
I don't know if Paul
North disagree with me,
let's see what what he will say later.
But in the fifties
in this traditional French
existentialism for example,
or all this philosopher,
or all these readers
coming from different political
and cultural traditions
let's think for example,
about the Jesuits in France
and neither, also in Latin America,
with liberation theology,
very significant social movements
and political ideologies
of school of thoughts.
I don't know how you wanna define this.
They are actually making a choice.
And the choice that they're making
is that they are reading
a particular Marx.
And this Marx is the so-called young Marx
which I believe is one
of the biggest inventions
in history of Marxists
that is again another
provocation from my discussant.
So I never said Marx would have done
this Marx would have said that,
Marx's would have voted
for this party, et cetera, et cetera.
But one things that
recently I allow myself
to say and believe me,
it's the only one is that
I am strongly convinced
that Marx's will be shocked if he will see
how much attention
the humanity has given to this manuscript
that he wrote when he was
only 25n 26 years old.
This beautiful, wonderful manuscript.
I want to say that I wrote my dissertation
on the "Economic and Philosophic
Manuscripts of 1844."
I love them.
I don't believe to them
who say this is not Marx.
But we cannot
overestimate the importance
of this manuscript
and do not study what just a Reitter said,
fetishism in capital
and also old the making of the concept
of alienation and
fetishism and reification
as I will show later by using the
terminology of Lukacs that started
in 1867 with the "Grundrisse" said.
I prepared something
so I don't wanna intervene
on this point now.
But what I want to say
is that unfortunately
and I will use this a
word in this big debate
about alienation and about Marx's
"Capital" was lost in many countries
and in many political translation.
And there was a very significant portion,
portion of readers or
the interpreters of Marx
who decided that the economical manuscript
over 1844 was the most relevant place.
I believe that this is wrong
because this was the idea
that "Capital" belonged to Soviet Union.
And that's dogmatic economist
the reading of "Capital"
was the correct reading of "Capital."
But I just want to say that
"Capital" was Marx's life
because Marx's wrote "Capital"
from 1857 from the introduction
that he wrote in July of 57.
Exactly at the same time
that the crisis started
that the crisis that I mentioned
before in New York because he said,
"Engels, I no longer have time to play
"the revolution is coming now
"and I must have my book out."
As always, he was wrong.
The revolution didn't come
but at least this was a first push
to have the first draft of copy down
the "Grundrisse" this eight notebooks
that he wrote in only a six months
and then this draft for "Capital"
they just ended in 1881 at the very end
when Marx was extremely
tired extremely old,
but I have no time to talk about this
unless you don't ask me to do it
but I wanna go back on this
division on this distinction
between the early writings and "Capital."
And this was around the
concept of alienation.
So the concept of alienation
was the key concept
in this vision of schools
of interpretation,
many people they belong
to different parties,
different cultures, different traditions,
different countries, different fields.
They decided that the
"Economic and Philosophic
Manuscript of 1844"
was the most important
text ever written by Marx.
And that the conception
of alienation that was there
was the most relevant one.
I believe that this interpretation,
as I just said is wrong
but also the second party
that is the party of after sale.
That is the party of
the Institute in Moscow
and many other people that were more
or less closer to the
dogmatic traditional Marxism
they refused the Marx of 1844.
And they even said that
that Marx was not Marxism,
and that actually Marxism started in 1845
with the German ideology,
with a book that now we know,
as I just said that did not exist.
So there is a problem also in this
other reading the reading of
the epistemological break.
If you wanna use a very famous expression.
And then in my division
of this three families
of these three categories
there is a third one,
which is the party of the continuity
between the early writings and "Capital."
And this is where I will co-locate myself.
I will go there if I have to decide
in which of these three ounces,
I'm going to live.
But in this part of the continuity
I have a many problems with actually
the majority of scholars who
belong to this interpretation
because I strongly believe
that there is a huge difference
between the analysis of 1844
and the analysis that
starts with the "Grundrisse"
that the analysis of alienation
the analysis of an initial that you read
in the "Grundrisse" that you read
in the "Theories of Surplus Values."
In many of the manuscript,
preparatory manuscript of "Capital"
that today we can read thanks to the MEGA.
And then this question of fetishism
that was publishing in "Capital."
Well, this is a much stronger analysis.
There is a much stronger understanding
of the social economical
issues in the society.
And I'm done Paul.
I see that you wanna intervene.
And there is also political.
There is also political
experience that was done by Marx.
So Marx is not only
learning from this book
but he's also learning
from this eight years
that he spent in international
and you learn many things.
So when he's posing this
question to him itself,
these are also questions that are related
to the organization of the society.
And that's why I've decided to dedicate
the last part of this contribution
to the question of the
alienation and communism.
Because I believe that
there is a strong connection
between this free society,
the contortions of this free society
and Marx's ideas of post-capitalism.
- It's terrific, I feel
like we're getting a view
of this one figure alienation
and how the streams of
Marx's own development
and reception and the reinvestment
in Marx's form whirlpools
around this term.
I'm kind of cut to the chase
kind of person sometimes.
And I wonder if we can say a little more
what was alienation in the manuscripts?
What was alienation and "Capital"?
Why do you think those other terms
like fetish or objectification reification
are translations of it or
take up some of its work?
Maybe this is one of the
parts of your presentation,
which is terrific.
- Yes. And as I said
before to Paul Reitter,
I will just like to share if you agree,
because I believe it's better
for the students who are listening,
unless you tell me that I better read
a couple of definitions,
but let's see if this works
and I'm going to share my screen here.
So hopefully you can see it.
Can you confirm?
- Yeah, we see it very well.
- Thanks. So I will go back
to this question later.
So to something that is related
to alienation Marx where,
because I said that is not only
or merrily or the most important in 1844.
So I would like to discuss
with you where we see the alienation
but let's go to this
question of the terminology.
It is very complicated because
if we go into the question of,
I'm just seeing Paul North now
because I have to read from my PowerPoint.
But if we go into this analysis
the etymology of the word early enough
for late in et cetera,
or the ward that alienation was used
I don't know in the
traditional political economy
like selling, this will
take a lot of time.
So I'm not going to do this, but I will.
I wanted to say something about Hegel,
because Hagel is of course very relevant
for Marx in particular
and not only for this Marx or 1844.
So the students who are listening to us
and now they are reading this,
they see that I am referencing to
"The Phenomenology of Spirit"
which Hegel published
in 1807, wrote in 1807.
If you want to wrote
if you want to know what is
"The Phenomenology of Spirit" for Marx,
you have to know two things.
Number one is something they
are wonderful and fascinating
and Marx said such a big
respect for this work.
But number two,
Marx said many times
in a couple of letters,
this is worse than going to the dentist.
Something like this.
If you wanna read it
if you won't understand,
it's extremely difficult.
So in this book,
you find this terminology "Entausserung"
which is literally self-externalization
or actually renunciation
and "Entfremdung" estrangement.
And Hegel is talking about
the spirit becoming other
than itself in the realm of objectivity.
I am actually more familiar
with the debate about how to translate
alienation in Italian, Spanish, et cetera,
and my English,
not only my thick accent is not the best
but we will discuss later.
And I will be learned from Paul Reitter.
And we will, I mean, you decide
if we want to discuss this more.
What is important for Marx
is the category of alienated labor.
That is entfremdete Arbeit,
which is what you find more often
in the EPM of 1844.
So Marx is here
expanding the problematic of alienation.
So the problematic of alienation
is not only related to
philosophy to religion.
When I say religion,
you have to consider
that Marx was part of this group,
the Left Hegelian and they
were trying to criticize Hegel.
And there is this famous
philosopher Ludwig Feuerbach
he's writing about religion.
So this is the beginning
of the tradition of materialism
but what is beautiful, really unique,
wonderful about this manuscript
is the fact that there
is a mix of philosophy and economics.
Sometimes a Paul North
I can only see you but Raymond Aron
the conservative French sociologist.
He wasn't making fun of all this
left this in the sixties, in Paris,
reading the EPM over 1844,
there are very brilliant quotations.
And you know, this is the kind of text
it was said that you use
when you want to impress
your boyfriend or girlfriend
when you wanna play the part
of the intellectual right
full of this wonderful quotation,
Hegel's mean et cetera.
It is when Marx actually fall in love
with political economy
because Marx's read
the political economist
in October, 1843 for the first time.
And by the way, thanks to Engels
because it was Engels
who was before Marx's
traveling to England,
looking at the contradiction of capitalism
and then reading the classics.
In any case alienation is
presented as the phenomenon
through which the labor
product confront labor.
And here's the quotation
"as something alien as a power independent
"of the producer from the producer."
So for Marx entails the role of the worker
in his product means not only
that his labor becomes an object
and external existence
but they did exist
outside in independently
and something alien to him.
And then it becomes a power
and Hegel's on confronting him.
It means that the life
which he had comfort
on the object confronts
him, her and something hostile and alien.
I don't wanna make this extremely boring.
But there are four ways in
which Marx define alienation
in the "Economic and
Philosophic Manuscript."
And there is a lot of
attention that has been paid
to this question of immaterial alienation.
So not only alienation is the process
in the factory of the workers, et cetera,
but also that you are alienated
from your species-being
right from all the humans.
There is, in my opinion
too much of this in many philosophical
interpretation in psychology,
we can discuss about
this later if you want.
Or when we open the floor to question.
As I was saying before,
I'll initial into "Grundrisse"
and all the preparatory manuscript.
I can not do quotations here
because it will be too long.
But I would like to take two more minutes
to show you where I find
many alienation in Marx.
So here is enriched by
a greater understanding
of economic categories.
Because Marx's had just started,
Marx's was not even reading
Ricardo and Smith in English.
Since we are discussing
translation a lot here
he was reading them
through French translation
and eco goes back to them in English
only later in the fifties when he's doing
the famous Londoner notebooks.
And there is also a more
rigorous social analysis
as I was saying before.
Perhaps I will say social
and also political analysis.
So this book written by Lukacs,
"History and Class Consciousness"
was very important as
it was very relevant.
Another book written by
Rubin about fetishism.
There's some political economists
because these two scholars even do
the mode right of alienation
hadn't started yet.
This big mode that I tried
to discuss at the
beginning with Paul North
when we say that the sixties
and the seventies writing of alienation
was almost a must if you were
in a department of philosophy
or political science without
this Gyorgy Lukacs in 1923,
he introduced another term
which is very relevant
for Marxist tradition.
The term of reification.
(speaking in foreign
language) is the thing.
So this is the term to describe
the phenomenon whereby labor activities
come from human beings
as something objective
and independent dominating them
through externals autonomous law.
This is interesting.
This is a remarkable
but something that many people don't know
is that Lukacs was actually used later
by those scholars and
professors, intellectuals
that I mentioned before.
Those who believe that alienation
in 1844 is the most relevant conception
of an initial made by Marx.
It was use my them because
in this book written in 1923,
Lukacs is still sharing the idea of Hegel
that every objectification is alienation.
It means that every society,
it doesn't matter if there
is a mode of production
that is a capitalist model production
or is a collective
socialist model production
you will have alienation there.
So Lukacs is very angry where
they are translating this
book in the sixties in French,
and it's also writing
a special new preface
for "History and Class
Consciousness" and his saying,
"I was to a Hegelian at the time.
"Now I change my position."
We can go back to this later
and also I want to dedicate one minute
to this question of the alienation
in so-called actually existing socialism
in the final part of my presentation.
Here is what the Paul
Reitter told us before.
So "The Fetishism of
Commodity and its Secret"
this is the section
in volume one of "Capital"
where Marx showed that
in capitalist society
people are dominated by the
product they have created.
Here the relation among them appear
not "as direct social relation
"between person and social, sorry,
"social relation between person,
"but rather as material relation
'between person and social
relation between things."
So fetishism is the name given
to the attributions to
things, commodities,
of what are in fact social relations.
So let's say that there
is any inversion process
that affect people in
the capitalist system.
And this is similar to the phenomenon
of religious fetishism.
There is a normal social religion
and they're replaced by
relation between things.
This is what Marx wants to say here
not opening the big discussion
about fetishism in religion
and the contribution
of Marcel Mauss in 1907
after criticizing what De
Brosses wrote about fetishism
which was a book that Marx read
when he was very very young
at the time of the university.
I'm skipping--
- Marcello, can I ask you
a question in the middle?
- Yes, you can.
I just wanna say that
I'm skipping this part
but this is the famous
definition that Paul was,
rephrasing in a very brilliant
way before and that we know.
So now I stop sharing
my screen and I'm back.
Please confirm that you can see me.
- We see you.
- Thank you.
- This is a quick question
but it's really what's most on my mind.
I feel like the danger
of the word alienation
in existentialism in other discourses
is that it'd be taken as
a psychological state,
a mood and affect with
which to see the world
or live your life
that colors the way things are.
It seems to me that you're saying
as you line it up fetishism
and objectification,
that it isn't a mood that it isn't
something an individual feels.
And in a sense this is what Hegel said.
It's a part of a process of constructing
the self in which the self confirms
that there's something other than it
by separating itself from itself.
But what do you think the
non psychological reading
of alienation is for Marx in "Capital"?
Where does it hit us?
Is it a matter of power and control?
Is it, are we supposed
to think about how we
react to a certain situation
or is it a structural issue?
- Thanks. Any remark question
or criticism from Paul Reitter?
Or can I go ahead with this one
and then there is more later?
- My dogs are barking right now
so I'm gonna leave it at that.
- Thanks. It was nice.
Yes, there's a period in which
we had something that might be called
the sort of irresistible
fascination of the theory of alienation.
It was the age of initial to core.
There was a a real bog
and the alienation just
to read a quotation from this article
that I shared with you
from various political background
and academic disciplines,
they identified alienation
the causes of alienation
is "commodification
"overspecialization, anomie,
"bureaucratization,
conformism, consumerism,
"loss of a sense of self
aiming new technologies,
"personal isolation, apathy,
"social or ethical imagination,
"environmental pollution."
So really this word alienation
didn't mean anything in the end.
And I also want to add one more point
before trying to answer to the lady
short but extremely difficult question
that Paul made.
That also in sociology alienation
completely changed the meaning.
Perhaps not in this sense
of looking at the individual
but in the sense that allegation
became something positive.
So four Marx alienation is clear
is always a negative phenomenon
that we have to try to fight.
Not to overcome forever
with just a revolution.
I will go back to this point later,
but to make it smaller, less
and Marx is also suggesting something
at least I will try to provide some ideas
in the final part of the talk.
In sociology and the
country in North America,
mainstream sociology they
treated our alienation
as a positive things.
And the question of how
you look at this concept,
this is completely different for Marx.
It is always the question
of the individual.
I'm thinking there's no
because I'm trying to borrow time
from the question of Paul,
but because actually I'm trying to answer
to this question in a,
perhaps a more difficult way.
So the individual is the center
for me means that the individual
must conform, must change.
So it is not the question
of social relations of the
society that must change.
It is a question of
adaptation of the individual.
It is a question that you are not looking
for solution general changes
but you're looking for solution
of the individual of their capacity
to adjust the capacity
to accept the existing order
and the practice of our society.
Now, why Marx is writing about this?
And what is the understanding of Marx?
What is the meaning of what is doing?
Well first of all,
I will say that in "Capital"
he is doing this because
he wants to understand the society.
So this concept is useful for us,
like many other concepts
that you will discuss
in this extremely brilliant
and wonderful seminar that you organized.
Like, for example, the question of money.
That it's so relevant for our life,
but it's so difficult to
define and to understand,
and this one too,
how was it possible
that our relations is
not a direct relation
but actually we interact with each other
through these commodities,
through these things.
So Marx is trying to understand
the society is trying
to describe the society.
And he's also using this
religious as he wrote here.
I call this fetishism,
which attach itself to
the product of labor
as soon as they are produced as commodity,
and is therefore inseparable
from the production of commodities.
It is not hitting this quotation.
And in order to find an analogy
we must take flight into the
mysterious realm of religion.
And this is what I
wanted to mention before
but there is one point that
is very relevant for me.
And here you I have a very reading
of mass conception of alienation.
I don't know if you agree with this,
but the difference
between this pages of Marx when he wrote
for himself as I will tell you later,
or when he wrote for an audience,
because he wanted to publish
because he published the book
that he was writing like
in the case of "Capital"
when we say the manuscript
that he wrote for himself.
Well, I read in this pages
a theory that is a theory
to understand the society
but also a theory to shake the society
to change the society.
So not only a coherent
theoretic theoretical basis
for understanding
capitalism and alienation
but also an anti-capitalist
ideological platform.
Like when I write in this article
alienation left the
books of the philosopher
alienation is no longer a debate,
even though brilliant
and fascinating that this young,
progressive left again
and we're having in
Berlin after Hegel died.
So it's not something
that takes place only
in the lecture hall of university
but it's something that
must go to the street,
must go to social movements,
to trade unions,
to political parties.
And in my opinion business
also why this concept
at such a strong fortune at least in,
I always think with my European eyes.
I see with my European eyes in the sixties
in the seventies,
because there was a fantastic political
and social movement that
exploded in those years
and these books of Marx,
even though they were written in
such a difficult and complicated way.
Paul Reitter is lucky
because he's really translating
"Capital, Volume I" and
not the "Grundrisse"
that would be perhaps
even more complicated.
I don't know.
I'm just also joking
that even the "Grundrisse" is so difficult
they could see that there,
that interpretational Marx
those ideas of Marx are also something
that belonged to their life
or useful for their life
and this is why they were so used
and circulated the words for many decades.
- That's terrific.
I think now we've set the
stage for the alienation
and hopefully what comes after it
or what might come after it, communism,
would you like to jump to that part?
- Yes, can I be
so impolite to take one more minute
and to go back to something
in my PowerPoint that
I think is useful for the youngest.
Can you see my PowerPoint here?
Thanks to the students who are here.
This is something that I've been editing.
It's ontology.
I don't wanna do advertisement
but it's a book that would
come out in December.
And I would like to tell you the work
that I've done in putting
together this ontology.
So "Alienation in Marx: Where?"
Okay, this is my question.
I wanted to reestablish the
relevance of economic writings
and of this better major
understanding of capitalism.
I don't like to use young major this word,
but at least we understand
each other by saving time.
I believe that we must
concentrate our attention
when we talk about alienation Marx
on the most relevant pages of Marx
later economic writing.
So not only the economic
or philosophical writings of 1844.
And I had to divide the book
in three parts for editorial reasons.
This is my research that
I wanna share with you.
Hopefully it's not too boring
but I want to try to explain this.
So when we look at this early
philosophical writings or to
what Marx wrote in the fifties.
There is not very much
about alienation after the 1844.
So this is "Notes on James Mill"
they were written at the same time
of the "Economic and
Philosophic Manuscript."
For me, actually they belong to the
"Economic and Philosophic Manuscript"
because Marx is just writing
these things for himself.
And there is a lot of about alienation
that is writing because he is stimulated
by this book, "Elements
of Political Economy."
After this big analysis
and putting together
a philosophy with political economy,
the concept disappears.
There are just few references
in the only family,
"The German Ideology."
But actually this is something that is
very small and Marx's,
sorry, know there is more.
Something that Marx is
very critical of this.
Is very critical because Marx's
is now speaking to an audience
that is no longer the
audience of this brilliant,
but very few philosophers in Berlin,
no Marx is in the political fights.
He is an activist in Paris.
He was exports from France, from Belgium.
Then he goes back to France in 1848,
who was talking to workers
and it will tell them,
you are alienated.
You are in estranged, you are reificated.
There is a fetish even do Marx
didn't know didn't use this expression
at the time with relation
to political economy.
Look what happened here.
So when Marx is starting
to write "Capital",
the first so-called draft of "Capital."
The "Grundrisse"
the "Outlines of the Critique
of Political Economy."
I found 11,000 words.
So I found a lot
because this is what Marx
is writing for himself.
So when we talk about Marx,
I'm sorry that you can not see me Paul
you tell me if I have to
put the PowerPoint down
or if more useful to show you this
but I will try to stop share,
and then I will come back.
So you can see me.
It is very relevant
for us to understand that
there is a difference
between what Marx wrote
to publish, "Capital."
And then there is the problem
of what Marx wanted to change
because Marx changed "Capital, Volume I"
in a couple of occasions,
and you will have done even more.
So not only you have to
know what is the difference
between what Marx wrote a very few project
compared to the many projects
that yet were completed my Marx
and they were published.
I'm exaggerating a little bit
but we can count them.
Then there are the manuscript
that Marx wrote for himself.
Like for example, the "Grundrisse"
self clarification, selfish standing
or preparatory writing
that Marx is drafting
and no, he's not satisfied
and move forward and forward.
Then there is journalism.
Then there is the correspondence
with all the people,
which was essential for
the political propaganda
and then the very relevant manuscript
note books in which Marx was
studying and was taking notes.
So when Marx is writing
the second category
of writings that I just mentioned now,
the manuscript preparatory manuscript,
you will find a lot.
This text number eight,
this is called the urtext.
So this is the preparatory texts
for the first book of political economy
that Marx published in 1859,
"Contribution to the Critique
of Political Economy."
So you see that there
is not very much there
but look Marx's is writing
about alienation extensively
not only in the "Grundrisse"
but also in
a draft that is only partially
translated into English.
That in the MEGA is called
manuscript 1861, 1863.
The MEGA is the German edition
historical critical edition.
And then in the "Theories
of Surplus-Value"
that Marx brought between 62 and 63.
There is a lot.
So I learn a lot when I read this texts.
I understand alienation
but actually more than
understanding alienation,
I understand capitalism much better
than when I read the texts of 1844.
And then the final part here, "Capital."
This really when Marx
is writing "Capital."
So these are not manuscript
written for himself.
This is a very important for us.
The so called "Unpublished Chapter VI."
Marx's returning on this question
with very brilliant, beautiful way.
These are all the places where
you find the ideas that
"Capital" is bombarded.
Mistaking the blood of
leaving labor, et cetera.
And then this is what
Paul Reitter mentioned
at the beginning, the
famous section of volume one
and there is also chapter
"Capital, Volume III."
Okay. So there is a lot of "Capital"
that is a lot of alienation that you find.
And the part that you find
in the early writings
is a very minoritarian
and perhaps not even
the most important one.
- Thank you, Marcello.
This is such a gift to have
all of this laid out for us.
I feel like we should open
up to everyone's questions.
They've been thinking this
through with you very soon.
I'm not sure if you want to
give an abbreviated version
of the, how to de-alienate
and is this how to,
do we have a recipe for de-alienating?
- I would like to leave the recipe
for the end in case somebody
is asking for a recipe,
let's see what happened.
Because the possible that
discussion would go there.
- Perfect. That's great.
- Ask you Paul if it's possible?
that I answer two to
three questions together
not one by one.
So we get more chances to
answer two more question.
I might be able to combine them if I can.
- Okay, thank you very much.
This would be a moment
in which there would
be thunderous applause
if we were in a flashy setting.
So we can all thank you for this.
It represents many years of work
and a couple of decades
of working through Marx.
- And you said that the
volume on alienation
this anthology is going
to be out in December.
- Yes, it's going to be
published on December the eighth.
- December 8th, excellent.
Well, congratulations on that.
- What I'd like to do is ask for questions
from the students in the seminar.
This is not a two tiered system,
but they're young and they're
just working through Marx.
So I wanna give them kind of first
opportunity to articulate their questions.
And then we will turn to anybody
and everybody who's
here who has questions.
So if the students would put
their questions in the chat,
then we will try to unmute the asker
and have them ask their question.
And we'll do a couple of
them as Marcello asks.
Don't make me take away from your grades
students if you don't ask questions.
That's all right, I'm not gonna do that.
Maybe we'll take some time for them to.
- I see many many questions here,
many interventions but
we are starting with
the student as you say.
- Let's start with Ali.
Audrey if you're there.
Would you unmute Ali?
- Yep. They are unmuted.
- [Ali] Hi, thank you very
much for your lecture.
I think it was really insightful.
My question refers to the initial remark
that you had about the revival of Marxist
reading following the 2008 crisis
and especially the political
revival in Latin America.
I wonder what you make of the revival
in Trotskyist's mobilization
as well significantly in Argentina.
Do you think it's a reaction
to the failed Bolshevik 'cause
or is it a sign of certain kind of
yearning for an internationalist approach,
a symptom of a methodology called vacuum
that we face right now
or more as a general question,
can revolution be alienated
on inside ideological grounds as well?
Just like to labor?
I don't know if it was,
if that was clear but...
- You said can any revolution
be alienated, right?
- [Ali] Yes, or as the revolution
and in its imagined forms?
- [Musto] Thank you.
- You're muted. Maybe we'll
take a couple of the other
questions that are in here.
Can we go back to Liz
Kinnamon or Kinnamon.
And would someone unmute her
and ask her to read her question.
This is complicated to do,
but I prefer to hear everyone's voice
or see their face when they're asking.
I think that's.
- Can you guys hear me?
- Yes.
- [Liz] So I actually made a
comment, which in a question.
So the question was Marcello,
are you saying that the
concept of alienation
as it appeared in the 1844 manuscripts,
that it kind of fractured
into multiple different,
more precise concepts like mystification
or commodity fetishism?
Is that, is that kind of your argument
about what happens to
alienation as it goes on?
- Thank you, and the remark?
And also, can you repeat your name please?
- [Liz] My name is Liz Kinnaman.
- Liz, right? Liz?
- Liz.
- Yup.
- Okay, let's go from there to one more.
We're already moved out of the realm
of the students who obviously all fail.
But that's okay, you're thinking people,
the students in this course are really
putting their best brain cells into this.
So it is true that it takes some time.
Could we open up the voice and picture
of Baruc Jimenez Contrera
who has comments and questions?
- [Baruc] Hi, I am interesting
in the topic of alienation and I have...
(internet connection distorts the speech)
I identify that before in
the manuscript of 1844,
they are another perfect tip of alienation
in economic history ideas
and specifically in other manuscript.
Why do you think that Marx
does not refer to discovery in his work?
- Thank you, Marcello.
- I had problem in understanding,
would it be so kind to repeat please.
(Paul speaking in foreign language)
(Musto speaking in foreign language)
(Baruc speaking in foreign language)
- Okay Marcello, this is three
do you wanna go ahead and respond?
- I think one more if you can,
but if there are no other question
I'm ready to answer.
- We have a student showing up.
Can we unmute Lawrence Lu, please?
- Sorry, I'm in midst of eating an orange.
I was really surprised by
your comments at the beginning,
when you were discussing like the sort of
different national revivals
of Marx's readings,
and you said that sort of
Chinese students ended up
and by that, I mean,
students in China ended up
focusing on certain issues and not others
and it made me think of
the sort of communist party
push right now for what they call
like socialism with
Chinese characteristics
and the sort of increasing pressure
that's being reported on academics
to sort of shore up China's
sort of brand of development,
like state and private development.
And sort of emergence of
a new international class,
of like Chinese political theorists
who are trying to like justify
like Xi Jinping's rule.
And so I was just wondering
how you see a relationship
between Chinese politics today
and the sort of new,
the new sorts of readings
of Marx that are coming out?
- Okay, Marcello your on.
- [Musto] You know the name of the last
student Lawrence right?
It was nice to see Lawrence
because I can see also his face.
So there are four questions.
And as I suspected,
and as I said to Paul
North and Paul Reitter
there is a lot of interest
for the "Marx Revival."
So I'm happy to hear about this.
I will start from this two questions
the last Lawrence and the first Ali,
because in my opinion they are connected.
So Lawrence, I have, as
I'm sure that you are
have understood for my presentation,
I don't share this
reading of a Marx's the Marxist Leninist,
the tradition in Soviet
Union imaging China today.
So I'm not saying that,
like some older scholars that
Marx's ideas are reviving
in China, et cetera.
What I was trying to say
is that I was led to see
and I look at this phenomenon
with a lot of interest
that in some of the main
university that I visited,
University of Nanjing when I work
as a visiting professor,
Fudan University in
Shangai even in Beijing,
even doing a little bit more complicated.
I saw many people engaged
in translating and bringing new readings
but only of Marx.
Marx's tradition and also,
philosophy for example
the author alters into Chinese.
And what I said, perhaps
I was talking too fast
or with my poor English,
that I was looking at
this in a positive way.
Like I was looking at
this as the possibility
to interact with a new generation
of students of scholars
also trying to listen to what they do.
It took me some time
but I found very interesting partners.
And now they're writing articles
and books and chapters
that I have to publish
or include in my edited volumes
or in the journal I collaborate
with or in my series.
I think it's very good.
So I went to that university and Nanjing,
and I saw for example
that they have an institute where
they translate Freda James on right.
And I'm was surprised
there is a lot of interest for that.
Recently there were some problems
because also some of this authors
that are translated sometimes
they signed petition against
oppressive political
decision of the regime.
And that's why they were also cuts
in the last year and a half, two years.
But I was just mentioning
the fact that it is good,
that this is possible now
and I see that the students in China
are also very hungry thirsty.
They want to read,
they want to learn or
they want to interact.
So this is a good.
To Ali, I wanna talk about Argentina
and my experiences in Argentina.
They were two conferences
in 2018 in Argentina.
One was the Bicentenary of Marx,
so they were doing this
kind of big conference
and they were able to get
there was a very conservative
government at the time.
One of the most conservative
in South America
they got in the end the big,
the biggest role, the
biggest venue which was
the museum all of the
library of the museum.
I don't remember the name now.
And they were expecting
a very big success.
They were expecting 500 people there.
When your organizer we're
walking that morning
and they came out from the subway
and look at the number
of people went in line.
They could not believe that
there were thousands of people.
And most of them were young people
many young women,
many young students
they were there because they wanted
to learn about Marx.
And they didn't even have an
impressive international program
with big names like Nancy
Fraser, David Darby.
They were just there because on Marx
they were just there because
it was a curiosity of Marx.
Myself I went to Argentina
the same year for an event.
And Paul you allow me,
if I can be a little bit biographical
and make it a little bit lighter
at this point of the conversation.
The same here there was the CLACSO.
They had the conference.
CLACSO is the organization
for social science in Latin
America and the Caribbean.
And it's about many things, many topics.
There are generally 40,000 people
who attend this event just coming
from outside your organizing country.
I was one of the guests
in the lecture about Marx.
There were two other guests.
One is Cinzia Arruzza
that you are inviting here in a few weeks.
And the other one is
as we this professor
who was a sociologist at Cambridge,
and his name is Goran Therborn.
And the three of us
were actually impressed
because we were hostages
in a very big room
which was packed,
like in a way that I never seen before.
And I was surprised to see
the bedroom was for Marx.
It was not from Diego Pavarotti.
One of my favorite Argentina actors
who was giving a presentation
in the room after.
So I went to the other presentation
but then realizes Marx was the place
with more people waiting
on the line outside.
So this is the kind of
enthusiasm that Marx is creating
in some parts of the world.
There are parts of the world
where you can not
mention the name of Marx.
And one of the geographical areas
where there are more problems is
for example, Eastern Europe
because they associate Marx
to that kind of communism.
So you will not see there.
Like, for example, Marx has not been read
in North Korea for at
least the last 30 years
by anybody even though they say Marxism
is what you see in North Korea.
So the party in Argentina,
which is a party that
I know very well comes
from this Trotsky's tradition
was the organization that existed
in Argentina was the most structured one.
And they were very successful
in responding to this demand.
So they entered in parliament,
elected many members of parliament,
they are active.
They give her a good contribution.
And if I may say one more thing
the most beautiful thing
that I've seen in Argentina
is this social movement
about the question of feminism,
this new generation of activism.
And they are also trying
to interrogate Marx.
I think that math will have to learn a lot
from them if he was alive,
but that kind of approach that they have,
the kind of look at the society.
I found it very close to
many things that Marx wrote.
I see that Paul wants to intervene.
- No, just a small comment.
I worry that with so many people
going to conferences on Marx's works
that they'll miss the revolution
if it actually happens.
You have a couple more
there and we have two more.
I'm just conscious of people's time.
So you have two more questions to respond
to maybe, and then we'll take
two more that are in the chat.
- That's a possibility in any case,
I am very happy to stay here
for all the questions
and to respond to all the students.
But I wanna force my chair to be there
for the end of the night.
So you decide.
Baruc, Marx didn't analyze Smith
because as I mentioned at the beginning,
and surely I was not clear
the concept of alienation
that you see in this Smith,
the problematic that you see
in "The Wealth of Nations"
is very different from
the way Marx's is using that word.
So the word alienation is something
that is more about selling.
If I understand your question correctly.
Why Marx is using alienation
as one of the main category in order
to explain to workers
because "Capital" was written for workers,
how crazy our society is,
our inverted are our religions.
Our social relations in
capitalist is mode of production.
And then Liz, the last
question, the second.
It was a very good one.
Yes, I think this is the
most difficult question
so far even more than one
that Paul asked me at the beginning
and I don't need enough
time to discuss this
but Liz is asking
are you saying that what we read
in 1844 is fractured in
a more concept later?
Well, I will say that what
that definition of alienation
is illustrating is for the point of view
of human relations,
the worker in the factory,
the worker with the other worker,
the worker with himself,
or in the relationship with the object
in the division of labor.
Then there is a concept of alienation,
which is what we discussed before.
Thanks for what Paul
Reitter said, fetishism.
That is a concept that is
alienation in relation to the commodity.
So I don't have time to
see exactly fractured
at each other, but they
are different angles.
One is the angles of the human relation
and the other one is the
angle of the commodity.
Then there is the big
question of the society.
And perhaps if I have
time I will go back to,
to something that I prepared,
but let's see what are your other question
and where we are going.
- Terrific, I'm going to
there's two that seemed
to lead from one to the other.
So I'm going to read for Félix Buquat,
whose microphone is not working.
His question in the chat,
the commodity fetishism is generally seen
as a defining characteristic
of the capitalist mode of production.
However, Marx does discussion
of the commodity fetishism and
capital proceeds has shifted
from exchange to production
and the introduction
of the class relation
between capital and labor.
What do you make of the
argument of George Henderson
and others that the commodity fetishism
is consequently applicable
beyond capitalism
due to its basis in
exchange and not production?
A technical question,
but and then if you want
to Alexander Kolokotronis.
Pardon my horrible pronunciation asks,
does Marx see the alienation
is something that can be total.
Is it a constant process?
And that gives you a chance to tell us
what you think that is.
- Yeah. I would like to
share my email address.
I don't know if it appeared
on the presentation of the lecture.
In any case it's my website is my name
and my surname marcellomusto.org
and people, students can write me.
Hopefully I'm not going
to get 15, 20 emails
but I will be very happy to discuss
this question that Félix is asking.
Paul helped me,
I don't know how I can do this without,
I don't know taking 10, 15 minutes
and saying goodbye to the
end of the conversation.
So I opted Felixs is not
angry at me if I will be
in touch with him separately,
because this is related
to a very specific things
and interpretation or government another.
And I might also provide
a couple of readings.
- As I ask along that line
do you have just a quick
answer to the question?
Is there non alienated labor
or is there non alienated,
non alienated sociality?
- That's one of the most
interesting point for me
and I will try to argue to answer
to this one in connection
with the other question,
just please Paul as admin.
Your question is how much
does the alienator really
on fetishism on subjectivity honest?
Is that one?
- That's one of them. Yes.
And then there's Alexander's
- Because I see Alexander there.
Okay Alexander, does Marx see alienation
is something that can be total
or the alienation is a constant process.
Good. So I will try to
discuss these things.
There is a very nice quotation from,
and he's talking about the fact that
at some point in Soviet Union
they did not want to hear
the question alienation.
They not want to discuss alienation
because they were responding simply
like we have socialism
therefore we no longer have alienation.
So alienation cooled
and must no longer be an issue for them.
I had the same kind of answer in China.
And I had a couple of
a brilliant professor
who were hosting me,
the conversation went to a social work
and the making of this new
department of social work,
by the way daily mainstream,
and American approach to social work.
And there is not enough political
in their social workers.
Work in Brazil is one of the
most progressive disciplines.
And it was also essential
the contribution that they had
for meeting people needed an activist
against a dictatorship.
So they said, "Why do
you want social work?
"We have socialism."
So there was this idea that socialism
is the end of the contradiction.
You find this kind of approaches also in
authors from Europe,
so called Western authors
for example, Lucianne Goldberg.
Lucianne Goldberg wrote about this.
And he said that it is possible
to overcome alienation definitely overcome
alienation in the social
economic condition of the time.
And he's actually writing that alienation.
I'm reading the quotation here
from is a dialectical research 1959.
Very important moment
for the alienation debate
is in fact a phenomenal,
closely one up with the absence
of planning and weed
production for the market.
He said that Soviet socialism in the East
and Keynesian policies in
the West were resulting
in the first case
elimination of verification.
And in the second case in a progressive
weakening of alienation
while I believe that
history has demonstrated
the faultiness of this predictions.
And this is not the position of Marx
even do Marx have been
read and described by this
teleology and this position
and easterly et cetera,
which is something that you find in Marx.
There are three, four passages
in which he's writing that way,
but sometimes these are political passages
so you have to be careful what
text you're reading sometimes
is also the fact that Marx
wrote thousands of pages.
And so you can find many things sometimes
because Marx was wrong.
So there are different answers
and options to this,
but his ideas is not that
you do the revolution.
You put a red star at
the top of a building
and there is no longer
alienation in that society.
And naturally these actually
existing socialism society
they prove to go in
the opposite direction.
Like for example when
the workers in Berlin,
in the so-called East Berlin
they were struggling against one
of the first measure that
was taken by the government
which was not the reduction
of the working day
but it was the increase
of the working day.
So you find this kind of things.
I would like to share
once again the PowerPoint,
if I'm allowed.
And I would like to say
what Marx wrote about this.
I don't know if at some point
we can make this PowerPoint available.
You can read this one.
So I believe that the
question of the alienation
the writing of alienation are
useful for the research that
the Marx did on communist society
the description of
post-capitalism society.
And I had prepared this question
that are essential question for Marx,
I can only list them.
Paul, don't be worried
just 30 more seconds, very quickly.
The essential topic for Marx.
A dealinated society,
a communist society as a society
in which there is an association
of few human beings full
and free development of every individual.
This is what Marx's looking at.
Marx is also talking about
social character of the production.
So I wanna make this clear
because I don't wanna be misunderstood.
I'm answering to the question.
I'm trying to answer to the question.
I'm trying to leave essential elements
in an organization on a society,
political, economical, social elements
that four Marx will make a
significant difference
compared to capitalism.
This does not mean for Marx
that this is the end of alienation
but this means that onc society
is introducing this elements
there is an improvement
and there are less chances for workers
to leave in the terrible condition
that we experienced under capitalism.
This question of the social character
of the production is one of them,
because Marx said that in socialism
in what do you call the
associate motor production?
You see this general product
from the beginning, not only in the end,
after decades of the market
and of the capitalist production
there is a log about
"planned corporation."
Marx is talking about this in volume one.
I'm sure that you will go back
to this with other guests
in the coming weeks.
Marx is talking about record in advance,
how much labor or many means of production
and means of subsistence.
Subsistence can be expand, et cetera.
I have no time, but
surely the idea of Marx
is to contrasting this free competition.
This idea of freedom of individualism
that is into capitalism.
Marx is in favor of the individual.
Marx consider the individual
as an essential element
to alienate the alienated the society
so that the individual
they have space to produce, to think,
to interact freely.
But his conception of
a freedom is different
from those of a capitalist.
"Individuals are subsumed
"under social production"
in capitalism wage labor.
So for Marx, the essential
question is the change
of the production and
not only on distribution.
The society will be much less,
significantly less alienated
if there is a change in the production.
And I provide a thumb,
definition in the article
on the communism that is,
has been recently published
in the "Marx Revival" that Paul North
was so kind to site
at the beginning of this lecture.
"Time and reduction of the working day"
is another essential element Alexander
of the alienation.
So the society should
go in that direction.
The direction that labor
is liberated is free
not for the copy that
is to exploit us more.
So, but for us to live in a better,
have a better life to be educated.
And there is ownership of the means
of production for Marx means change
the lifetime of society.
And this is what we are
talking when we talk
about the alienation is not
the philosophical formula.
So non-alienated society
is free development.
I don't have time to talk about this
but there is this famous quotation
of volume three of "Capital" when Marx
is talking about the realm of freedom.
- I think it really
couldn't talk about this
if you want to Marcello,
we have 10 minutes in
the allotted time and--
- I was so worried,
and I can not see how
many questions are there.
- A lot of questions and very good ones.
We might not get to all of them,
I'll try to save them
and send them to you.
But this seems like an important topic.
- Thanks. I was just trying
to drink a little bit.
So I'm gonna spend just
two minutes about this.
I wanna return on this question
which is I'm still creating problems,
in my opinion in many contemporary
political readings of Marx.
So what is freedom for Marx?
Marx wrote about this.
I find a lot of this in
the preparatory manuscript,
and sometimes also in the letter,
even though there are all other treasures
in notebooks in the excerpts
that is what I use for the
analysis of the last Marx.
But this will be the topic
of another conversation that
we will let in the future.
So if we focus on non-alienated society,
so Marx is writing about this question
of individual freedom,
living in a non-alienated society meant
building a social organization
in which a fundamental value was given
to individuals freedom.
This is me writing.
Now I'm going to quote
from the "Grundrisse"
because Marx in the
"Grundrisse" and not only
there are several manuscript
in the late fifties
which Marx is very angry
about the foolishness
of those socialists Marx here is thinking
about French socialists in particular
and his contemporaries like Proudhon,
not Saint-Simon and Fourier.
Marx had a tremendous respect for them
like for Robert Owen.
These French socialist
contemporary two Marx the false brother
of socialism and Marx
called them in "Grundrisse."
They want to depict socialism
as the realization of the ideas of
bourgeois society articulated
by the French revolution,
who demonstrated that exchange
and exchange value, et cetera,
were good at the beginning.
But they were perverted later by capital.
It is just a question of capital,
it is just the question of distribution.
These are so important
political questions.
The international is the
beating about this a lot.
The difference between Marx and Proudhon
is not about misery or philosophy,
poverty of philosophy,
philosophy of poverty.
This is the 1847 polemics.
If you want to understand the difference
between Marx and Proudhon
you have to go to this manuscript
of the 50th board of them.
And then the political
struggle that is up in India
International when there
are two different conception
about out organized and
normally unaided society.
One is looking at distribution, Proudhon.
One is looking at the change
on the production, Marx.
So Marx is writing into "Grundisse"
"free development under
the domination of capital
"was the most weeping abolition
"of all individual freedom
"and the complete subjugation
"of individual two social condition,
"which assumed the form
of objective powers
"indeed of overpowering objects
"independent of the individuals
relating to one another."
You see that the concept is there.
The idea is there and is developing this.
Now "Capital, Volume III"
which was written by Marx
before "Capital, Volume I."
Because the main draft belongs to 1865.
So this is the famous quotation
that I don't want to read.
When Marx is talking about
the realm of freedom is,
I just got this quotation here.
I will just call your attention
on this very, very short part
because generally it's
quoted it's 500 words.
It's one full page.
"The realm of freedom really begins
"only where labor determined by necessity
"and external expediency ends.
"Freedom can consist only in this,
"that socialized human,
"the associate producer,
"govern the human metabolism
"with nature in a rational way."
By the way, there is
so much ecological Marx
in this manuscript,
preparatory manuscript of "Capital."
As my colleague Kohei Saito
has demonstrated recently,
after a lot of good
scholarship on the topic.
And, "accomplishing it
"with the least expenditure
"of energy and in conditions most worthy
"and appropriate for the human nature."
So this is the quotation
in which alienation the end of alienation,
the real conception of freedom
and the reduction of the working day
is they are altogether.
So this is a very well known alienation.
I end by saying this,
that this post capitalist
society of production
together with all the
progress of technology,
the reduction of the working day
they create the possibility
is not guaranteed.
It's not a necessity is never the end
because the contradiction
will start once again.
But there is a possibility
for a new social formation
in which the cohesive alienate
the labor imposed by capital.
We're talking about wage labor of course,
and subject to it's laws
is gradually replaced with something
that Marx called sometimes
a conscious creative
activity beyond necessity.
And this is what Marx's
called is the real realm
of freedom the genuine
realm of human freedom
which is very different from
the realm of freedom for capital
that we have in our society.
You should see me
should be able to see me if I'm not wrong.
- [Paul] Thanks.
There's so much to say
we're just getting started.
You're right that
you need an all night
seminar on alienation.
I think what we should
do is thank the people
who came and asked questions.
There are some still littering the chat
filling the chat that
are really quite good.
How would you conceptualize
the relationship
between alienation and abstract labor?
There are questions
about Michael Heinrich.
An important about Feuerbach
and the development of
the idea of species-being.
But I really do think we
need to leave it here.
- I have a good answer to this.
And the answer is that your organize
the seminar with 12 lectures
and there is a lot of room
and food for thought for the colleagues
that will come after me.
- Thank you very much.
We really appreciate your time
and all of this wonderful work.